this question to all cast from everlark
Sunset
Twitter can you do the mocking J whistle
Al together
please I got to be honest every time I
try and do it it comes out as like the x
file xile
yes like
[Music]
exactly that was pretty good
help somebody help
me's doing it really well over here
that's very is that you you're eerily
good at it unless you have a Cage bird
with
you I haven't done this in a really long
time I don't think my character ever
does this there's like 5,000 people I'll
just say yeah now you're just doing
it and it's feeling creepy yeah do your
Josh has a cool skill dud
funny I've heard that when I tell jokes
sometimes
uh
recently that's good got a ple of animal
how did you find out you could do
that what took you to know you could do
that lots of time I'm my home yeah yeah
not many
friends